as you know it's women's history month
and I am so excited because we teamed up
with Hershey's and this year the iconic
chocolate bar will highlight she at the
center of her she each bar features over
200 encouraging words curated by
Hershey's and their Partners Girls on
the Run now every day at our show I'm
inspired to work with women who are
caring smart humorous compassionate and
so we're shining a spotlight on three of
them Caris Jenna and Harry Anna are
producers on this show that I have
worked alongside with every day since we
launched three years ago and I just love
them so much so check out women who
Inspire them my best friend Jamie is so
inspiring she is talented she's smart
she's independent and she's courageous
she quit her traditional nine to five
job to chase her dream of opening her
own wedding photography business when
the pandemic happened she was a little
bit worried but she didn't let it stop
her today she's one of the most sought
after wedding photographers in New
England and on top of that she's about
to celebrate the one year birthday of
her son Waylon I'm so inspired watching
Jamie go through all of these life
changes all while being a new mom love
you James
my mom is my inspiration she's warm
caring thoughtful she commuted every day
for the past 30 years for four hours for
work and showed us how to push
boundaries at work while still being so
involved in our lives she never missed a
field trip a dance recital and was never
not a constant in mind of my sister's
lives she's truly always putting others
first she's taught me what it is to be a
great mom when I become a mom in just a
few short months let me tell you if she
makes a mean batch of Meatballs
my best friend Rachel since the age of
seven is my inspiration she's smart
she's kind she's loyal and she's
resilient at 22 years old she suffered a
stroke and was forced to learn to walk
and talk all over again fast forward to
today she has her master's degree she
receives her certifications to practice
mental health counseling she accepted
her dream job offer and she is
celebrating the one year wedding
anniversary to the love of her life
Rachel I love celebrating you for who
you are
[Music]
[Applause]
my friends actually and acknowledge a
woman who inspires me daily and she has
no idea that I'm doing this right now
Lauren Galino where are you
oh there she is
um so Lauren is an amazing makeup artist
um who I am lucky enough to work with
every single day and when she saw
because we weren't allowed to have food
in the pandemic because of all the
restrictions Lauren feeds the entire
crew with snacks she does
she has a wonderful
hunt and two amazing children and I just
wanted to present you as the she and
Hershey's you're my she and you're my
hero
[Applause]
Justin
how do you be so good to everybody such
a good friend such a good mom such a
good co-worker I love what I do and I'm
very lucky to do what I love and be with
the people that I love and very
fortunate because a lot of people aren't
as fortunate and they wake up and they
don't want to go to work I wake up
at three o'clock in the morning and want
to go to work you are human love and we
love you I love you
thank you
now I bet everyone in our audience
probably has a special girl or a woman
in their life who inspires them so we're
sending everyone home with a variety of
limited edition her she's she bar to
share with someone
who has made
it in your life and if you want you can
film it and tag our show because we love
creating moments here to share with each
other how we feel about each other
that's so important to do it in the
present and in the now so I love you man
all right we'll be right
we'll be right back
[Music]